this video is brought to you by better help as
three people proud to be in therapy we are proud
to be partner with them for the month of November
citizens of the reject Nation we are here for the
Loki season 2 finale John how are you I am
terribly voraciously anticipant all right
let's see Coy how that's right he's running late
of course he is don't worry he'll be here guys
which will give us time to do a little shout out
to everyone who has bought real rejects merch at
www. reject Nation shop com my guys thank you so
much and ladies for all the support you have been
giving our way and looking good while doing it
we got shirts like Marvel inspired space babies
of the Galaxy we also got Marvel merch John's
rocking this Loki shirt this other Marvel shirt
but we also got stuff like Pedro Pascal from Last
of Us carrying baby grou Child Protection Services
my personal Fai but we also got citizen King
we got who influences The influencers Watchmen
inspired we also got some Ahsoka inspired te's
we got more development got this America's ass
from the boys universe that's another one of
my personal favorites and we got a whole bunch
more either one that you buy is one of the best
ways my personal favorite way for you to support
the channel so thank you guys so much with that
in mind leave a like on this video also another
thing to thank you all for for supporting the
channel thank you so much for becoming super sexy
rejects that's where you get the full length
through R and watch along where you syn with
your own copy of Loki and we also cover several
shows exclusively over there with reaction high
and watch alongs included all righty guys let's
get into action you ready koi that's son of a
[Music] [__] I don't notice anything different
about the music nothing what are you talking about
Echo backwards damn good [Music] catch cool
they're all
disappearing whoa into the comics we go this
is trippy that was cool into the pen and inav
verse oh I'm going to miss this show
yeah it's really good yeah buddy it's
hard to be brave is he not telling
them hey is it right now yeah got it
grab himy how long will he have not
long about this radiation level it's
even worse than when I was out there speak up loie
more what if we just repeat all of episode
5 that's the whole episode oh different
angle okay so we're not just fixing things I
think he has to see how it failed what could
we have done differently we took too
long oh go back to episode one again
fost they are just he's going to come
to bargain okay no time to argue okay
cool cool get down the gangway load the
multiplier hit the green button launch
it and get back okay it's exactly way
wonder how much failure there's going to
be instantaneous Ely what happened he's gone
again not faster is it over earlier wow this
is really the Mastery of time minutes
I know right now you're hurt and you're
angry finishing theit multiplier
fast just in the middle of the
nerious plan oh my God that's awesome
I wasted time and now does time waste
me oh my god oh before we even get through the
doors I wonder what number we're on oh come on
come on come on come on come on steps no oh that
skeleton again introdu can you time slip to like
he who remains this is Ora Boris guess what the
TVA handbook you both wrote it so this model is
now finished what are you talking about it's
absolutely perfect this is like an improv game
where they want you to speed it up why me because
you volunteered you did you will and you know how
the multiplier Works it'll make sense it will make
sense I love how we've had franticness so much of
this show and now we're having fun frantic yeah
it's like joyously frantic not as tense Obie how
long will it take me to know everything that you
know about mechanics physics and Engineering oh
my God he's going to become a genius the god of
story is getting all data but I'm a fast learner
and I'm a God yeah you are how long would it
take decades centuries Commit This is like a
Doctor Who episode wowow yeah is like a Doctor Who
episode low I'm not questioning your surprisingly
Advanced engineering skills centuries later now it
looks lethal it is absolutely safe watch this I'll
take those thank you when you're ready chop a man
in control I love how this really does feel like
lowkey show we have to move fast who's it going to
be it's him it's you you volunteer what about the
IR 9 is fine no it's not going to overheat because
would allow it to interface directly with time's
adaptive expon ping system it would allow the loom
to scale the capacity to manage the backlog of
branches Tom H Hillson doesn't even know what he's
talking about yep he said centuries like watching
someone do Shakespeare it's beautiful like I
don't know what you're saying but I get cuz you
get it don't forget to latch his helmet that's
latch his helmet thank you thank you does this
Victor accept he is becoming the
king of the TVA if you stop you
die oh [__] oh boy five episodes leading
to back to being in the lowkey show was
interesting oh that was such a great C that
pause was perfect come on buddy and load the
multiplier into the launcher that's it one
step at a time got to keep going be brave
you're being so brave many times you given bra
you're being so brave that was hilarious is so
good one foot in front of the other everything
he needs to hear before you know it you'll be
at the end of the gang way what a guide well
done looks on everyone's faces the nonchalant
of the direction oh you made it not yet yeah
seriously how many times have you gotten this
far do not put the multiplier down it will roll
off Victor come on there it is there it is push
through come on buddy it's just time it's Lo he
who remains wanted lowkey to be in that's what
he offered him at the end of last season this
is all still him in control this is all still
he who remains plan I feel it it's all still
him watching too like right here come on push
turn there it is oh come
on bud hit the green green
right listen to me carefully I love how there's no
music something's bound to go
wrong no what about that other
greenish bluish green it can be a little sticky
green y oh my
God yes good POV get back back yes come back
I love you Victor beautiful beautiful man go
go go go go oh the joy the [Music] relief now
let's watch Victor become a villain yeah and now
he is K we did it team oh wait for those doors to
close come on come on come on come on come on yes
pumpkins pumpkins what do you see it's working he
did it w cool it's working right now really it's
working he's got his arm around him
what an antithesis to the last season
yeah truly I mean he spent Centuries with him it
worked oh no still too much how come the L be
overloading all these great lens flares it's
not possible we increased the throughput I'm
Legit feeling the frustration right now mhm
the handheld is so perfect it's so subtle
but there are just too many branches it's
still like an ocean through a water hose just
a bigger water hose the branches of time are
duplicating and expanding uhhuh infinite rate
oh boy it's a scaling problem uh ium will never
be able to accommodate for an infinitely growing
Multiverse well yeah I mean I love how the setup
at the Multiverse is feeling malevolent no
matter how much we increase the throughput
it will never be enough enough never enough yeah
cuz you'll just have to always keep increasing
the throughput if it's infinite as soon as the
timeline started branching this was doomed to
happen Doom Dr Doom Loki don't go back nothing
you can do all right what's the singularity you
might as well just have fun hopping through time
yall did your best I'm sorry oh you don't need to
be sorry man you only just learned about this
like yesterday in your time and you did great
oh bring him back they're going to bring back
he who [Music] yes oh [__] that's what king
probably wanted the whole time stop is this re
shot I can't tell they look great I felt what
you feel okay wowe I wonder if he who remains
will know what's happening you're right oh this
is e as what were you thinking trusting me put
him right up against that framing you must not
follow through it all ends if you do I've seen it
I've lived it so many times you've been seduced by
a throne the last thing I want is a throne
you'll have to kill me does he kill Sylvie
Jesus I me you can just keep
time slipping back to this
moment yeah he's come to bargain
why you figure out a way just to
incapacitate not what you were
expecting H don't tell me I'm
a disappointment but not even he who
remains can anticipate this huh or has
he hear me out hear me out you have to
kill me [Music] I wonder how many times
he has seen this yeah if you want to stop
me you'll have to kill me come on you can
figure out a way to not kill her why do
you never try to stop her fight back do
something holy [__] could have stopped
the whole time how many times have you been
at this see he knew oh come on you're not
telling me you haven't learned how to pause
time yeah why don't we just uh who Holy balls
this is crazy he's conquered time this isn't
the first time we've had this conversation how
did you know I know about the slipping and who
do you think paved that road any guesses of course
he who remains got in one Theory right this whole
time thinking you were you were sticking it to the
system going to beat the man and and then whoop
here he is it's interesting to see him capturing
this kind of handheld did you really think I was
just going to sit back and let her kill me and
that be it is Zip N rip hwr reincarnation baby
it's right there in his name he's he who Reed we
die with a dying we're born with a dead uh-huh
okay uh this is a lot for you why don't you just
go through this a couple thousand more times get
your bearings you just let me know okay when
you're ready to have a conversation oh just
have the conversation man reminds me of Lucifer
and Supernatural now such a fun way to play the
character you figured out how to
do it on he know it was possible
and what makes you think this is the
first time we've had this conversation
booah hold done you're my favorite you know that
when there's two of you here you were my favorite
seems you figured it all out h Huh interesting
POV how is Victor timely you're you're having
some some some problems with the the temporal
Loom pretending to be a Min reader SC problem
that's what he told you Victor told you it was a
scaling problem wow the temporal Loom is a fail
safe deletes everything except the sacred timeline
huh and the TVA well that's just that's just
collateral damage no no Big Easy to rebuild oh wow
but a waste of time nope my variants are already
out there there's too many i w stop doesn't matter
they're in a Coliseum in one place they're all
together the outcome to this equation remains
good Cho it Remains the Same Song Remains the
Same shake it off it's interesting being back here
where this room is lit so much more by the fire as
compared to the last season definitely suits The
Season's Vibe more I'll change the equation you
did just do all that math and physics learning
but the loom prevents a brutal War where nothing
survives low key not even in the sacred timeline
but how does This Ti to Echo peace you've ever
experienced I was here what do you think would
happen to your friends how much far ahead to
see I make the tough choices everything that's
why I get the big chair Big Boy chair can't you
see what I'm offering here but what was the
purpose of this for me or for you I'll find
another way Thor yes we'll do the God help me
is this and around and around and around we
go where stops nobody knows break the loom and
you cause a war that kills us all or End Game
Killer scales and we protect what we can ooh
the trolley problem with your variant that you
love what are you going to do great cut wow
how far back are we going to go play out scenes
from my whole life how it's all meant to be
burdened with glorious purpose he said it okay
it looks like someone got a hold of the set list
how do you choose who lives and who dies this
is all an origin for God of stories it was the
proper flow of time there's no Comfort you're
not going to find Comfort at the TVA a couple
of Hunters went out on a mission somewhere near
near the Black Sea to find a variant who's going
to be responsible for 5,000 deaths interesting
the variant is an 8-year-old boy Slaughter the
8-year-old boy so what must be done he had never
hesitated but that day he did happened so fast
his partner had to step in and brunin the kid oh
no is a tough decision D couple Hunters died all
because that one Hunter he lost sight of the big
picture who's that Hunter most purpose is more
burden than Glory and trust me you never want
to be the guy who avoids it cuz you can't live
with the burden yeah buddy great way to use his
line back at him how do you live with it I love
how this is mirroring so much of season one
right now what happened to your partner it's
not even like a mirror is a question things
worked out fine for her she actually became a
judge she knew the hard thing to do was the
thing that had to be done o damn it no there's
no comfort you just choose your burden there's no
comfort you just choose your bur that's a poignant
ass line he went and got back to get advice
from Mobius is so beautiful he made that hard
Choice oh [Music]
W into the void no left
go man the meticulous mapping out of this
serious credit to the writers on this man
let's map this out structurally is nuts I
finally learned to control the time slipping
I went back he's so weary now it was designed to
protect the sacred timeline and nothing else I'm
out of option syia oh jeez the only way that
anything surv if I never kill he who remains
in in the first place Sylvie might have the
answer to this so you have to kill me unless
you could go back and convince yourself
how would be able to go back though you
know maybe you can just like take her with
it that's not how time still it's not how
the force works it's the sacred timeline
or nothing it's not enough to protect the
sacred timeline Loki damn the consequences of
her choices I grew up in Apocalypse as Loki
I've lived through enough of them to know that
sometimes it's okay to destroy something but
everything but every if there's a hope that you
can replace that thing with something better POV
just make feel like they're talking to us this
is so strange must been so hard to act at the
lens now there's a grander plan why
would he who remains want this to
happen he's definitely still in control
I just can't figure out what his goal is
he's becoming God of stories but we're
ultimately watching The Narrative of
he who remains right this at the end
of the day is the Kang power [Music]
story this is incredibly sad
the burden he's been burdened
with glorious purpose yeah I love
that they brought that all back to
this if he goes out there he can't
time slip back can he open the door
ly what are we doing I know what
I want I know what kind of God
I need to be one who serves the
people for all of us for all time
always whoa absorb all of
time wow dude the end of the
thing SH now this looks like a
comic book oh he's back in his comic
outfit yeah that was sick wow that's
awesome yes come the
horns oh how
striking who magic it's
the Richard E Grand version
almost
whoa that's all I had to do this
whole time so there is no sacred
timeline it's just a which is how we get Fox and
Sony incredible look at that wow they
look so tangible it's actually cool
everyone
lives or are they like necro timelines
now can actually touch the
bridges he is a God wowe he is a God so what's
happening to that part on that timeline where
he's gripping it yeah what did happen when he just
Enchanted it was there like a natural disaster w
cool how you going to power them
all damn this is some truly sci-fi [__] right
here we've entered love craan territory where are
the Elder Gods Cosmic hor
he's like a full Norse God
now there it
is whoa Indiana Jones Jehovah starts with an
eye man it's like an Assad be strong that is
beautiful wowe
whoa sure
enough I love how it's this green
magic Rippling through all of it
wow nice stretch Zoom he
making his way to the end of
time sit and watch it all from here
[Music] these visuals are [__]
dazzling why do they look better
than a recent Marvel movie by a
lot look at that just tethered through
all of it his cape as part of time like
a painting wowe beautiful that operatic
Godly music is he the man at the beginning
of time and Victor timely's at the end of
time does he represent the stories that
in and he like watches over as they
[Music] end whoa ourglass Fades Into
Obscurity jeeez sit on the
throne that's what he's always
wanted now do a pictoral fly get
out whoa
damn let's go to the first Iron Man movie
now Back in Black oh where we're going to
land Tree of Life yeah oh we're
on Pandora just the mixture of
the colors of the purple and the green
yeah making it roots in a tree that was
stunning after let me know if you need
anything's going over here
talk about restoration ah
Miss minutes are we sure she won't try to kill us
all it's a risk I'm willing to
take so Obie may miss you okay
I got those reports on the variance
of he remains oh boy I guess one of
them caused a little bit of a ruckus
on 616 adjacent but they handled it
[Music] so he's going to learn about himself oh
it is a good reminder those who do not remember
past or you know better off not doomed to repeat
it certainly you're leaving you think the TVA is
going to miss a tired washed up old analyst
yes yes we will I think there is one or two
who will you're the best MCU character got to go
see what exactly it is would been protecting if
you ever want a seat in there yeah if you
get sick of those kids they need you in
there hug it out or at least get some
pie for the road somber man were you
scared oh yeah it's good it's good
you want to be scared you want to be
uncomfortable how big the room looks looks around
them just so funny how the start
of the season the TV agent seems
so goddamn threatening now it just feels like
family yeah yeah people picking up the pieces
a first edition was yellow where's Victor
let me put him back oh hey buddy oh is
he not going to get it now dropped off
playboy 1974 then Victor Tim became a sex
addict hey oh the end of
time it's like some ethereal ponderous Alex
Garland [__] it really is look what you can
make Marvel what you can become I really feel
like it's got that dark heart of aronowski Lac
throughout now everyone she helped prune is
going to be there waiting for their pound of
Flesh oh snap oh that's a cool reveal whoa
wow oh theor Boris good thing
she landed right there elath
it's really does look like Ohio Loki said he
could be placed back exactly where he was left off
at and now it becomes a Wes Anderson the Y
could do a bit of work prune it no Christ
it's the best house on the Block never look
never know it's my my policy where you going
to go McDonald's the train back to work yeah I
might just wait here for a little bit go ride
your jet ski let time pass just actually feel
time should do a season 3 where he kills this
other version of himself takes realizes
he hates these kids yeah made a horrible
mistake let time pass just feel t stand in the
river and let it wash over your ankles be in the
moment oh Loki's listening they're
braided like Norse
braids
wowe I love this Tri D in music that was so cool
Still Still minor still somber yeah it's a very
sad success day col man the day after a Triumph
is as Hollow as the day after a tragedy man
Aaron and Justin are gonna make some beautiful
Daredevil that was some somber heaviness that
vartic article's full of [__] that was a great
finale did it say the finale was bad I thought
they we were in trouble or something oh yeah you
know Marvel's up it's done he's the beginning of
time I I what a beautiful Arc for that character
B made Cosmic and time so grounded like that's
my exact that's a comic because I usually say I
prefer grounded stories and characters but when
you can do this big and ground it when you've got
the emotional grounding they don't even know what
Loki did they don't know what he did exactly
do they I suppose they wouldn't oh wow no post
credit scene get focus on this no trailers for
nothing feels like the antithesis of a lot of
recent Marvel stuff letting the story breathe and
not having it set up 100 other things don't be
sexist Co I know what a sexist story also somehow
racist yeah you know just cover all your Prejudice
I mean while we're here holy [__] man it seems
like it' be very lonely to be the god of stories
sitting on that throne and then all these people
having to get in touch with their identities and
their feelings and how they I think we all know
where we're going with this guys before we talk
about this I want to be selfish and just sit alone
in your throne yeah get yeah that's fair that's
fair there it is thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video I've literally just finished
a therapy session and I wanted to shoot this cuz
I'm in this state of knowing why I Champion mental
health support so much in the past few weeks
work's been a little bit hectic it's led me to
miss some sessions and I really don't like doing
that and sometimes that's when the weight really
starts to pile on a lot of restless nights a lot
of fatigue a lot of I can't sleep even though I'm
so tired sometimes just a very deep-seated sense
of gloom and yeah every time this time of year I
get the seasonal Blues like many of you meditating
and sometimes journaling are my daily go-tos but
sometimes they just don't cut it when I'm trying
to pinpoint why I'm down and really especially
after a session like today therapy just really
helps clear the fog discussing the feelings is
a critical step for me especially as someone
who's diagnosed with ADHD type 2 bipolar and
PTSD it's truly a Cornerstone in my well-being
and I'm not alone in this many of us here at real
rejects are in therapy facing our own challenges
from depression into anxiety or just needing a
non-judgmental space to voice our thoughts this
year I've been working out most days of the week
to keep my physical health strong and I really do
Champion therapy as a way to strengthen my mental
resilience and for many betterhelp is integral to
that process There's real value in better help's
accessible and adaptable service they match
you with a licensed therapist and provide the
option to switch if necessary ensuring the right
fit for your mental health Journey as this year
winds down and we confront life's complexities
do consider betterhelp as a resource really happy
to be partner with them this month so you can
go to betterhelp.com rejects for 10% off your
first month again that's bet t r h lp.com comreal
rejects so join us and moving forward stronger
together thank you again all right thank you to
better help for sponsoring this video okay um wow
I thought that was really impactful finale uh very
very strong I got to get koi out of here and I got
to edit so there's nothing really more to say
I'm sure John likes it he likes everything and
Coy uh loves everything yeah likes loves and then
you got to hate it because of us to give the FL I
got a nitpick yeah I mean so it's a sneak preview
balance are you saying you're the god of stories
and how revie are you writing the story of our
reviews yes um but no Coy why don't you quickly
explain what the god of stories is so I love the
story of the god of stories because it actually
mixes in with a meta narrative without actually
being meta so in the meta Narrative of Deadpool
for example or She-Hulk it is a roing the fourth
wall or breaking the fourth wall acknowledging the
reader in Loki's use of the fourth wall it's
actually acknowledging the house of ideas and
the house of ideas is what they used to call the
bullpen the place that Marvel wrote their stories
the house of ideas was the concept of creation
itself in the Loki story of the god of stories
they made the house of ideas a a tangible finite
element which he was the first one that was able
to remember his visit to the house of ideas so
throughout comic history in this story other
people had visited the house of ideas but no
one had heard remembered so Loki made a deal
with then and now these these abstract entities of
pure storytelling and in making a deal with then
and now and upon remembering the house of ideas
itself he is able to make things real by way of
remembering them and telling them as a story
so he's able to articulate what reality is by
way of him planting the memory him manifesting it
and then him actually creating it in real time so
it's rapid creation through the powers of then
now and the house of IDE as itself and so this
was the visual manifestation of that of basically
he's the one at the beginning of time controlling
the timelines because he's the one that needs
to Monitor and create like pure creation so
my interpretation of this is that Kang is the
destroyer by monitoring and thinking that's the
answer he's at the end of time not a destroyer in
the literal sense but that it's the it's the the
atrophy the the the the the dismay the decay
of time he's at the End of Time whereas Loki
with the green and the Lush and the other side
of colors is at the beginning of time which is
why it's said after period for the TVA so so he
literally is creation and in a way he uh Kang is
destruction by being the Conqueror of something
so now there's a more giant more abstract Ora
Boris yeah that's beautifully put wow you did that
very efficiently thank you well done yeah that was
not an easy story no it wasn't I was like a little
worried how I'm gonna get through this dense dense
thing yeah well yeah I mean but in the context
of the sto of the show itself I think they they
don't ever call him the god of stories here no
I mean this is kind of the origin of it but they
don't we haven't seen him storying it up yet no
no and he's burdened with that glor like I love
the Glorious purpose like cycling back because
before it was his arrogance of wanting to have
purpose his arrogance of wanting a throne and
through that burden he became malevolent and I
love that now he's burdened with glorious purpose
and the weight of the throne so his burden and
that speech about purpose is so beautifully anoris
yeah and burden with glorious boredom you know I
can imagine how I mean while being in touch with
the timelines and seeing every single story that
is unfolding you know God of stories allows for
a bit of a narrative control and it's interesting
for Loki to be a villain who has arked into this
ultimate power following a comic book Arc yet he
is the um benevolent uh Counterpoint to to King
and is this something I mean there's always a
conversation about they need the balance they need
the antithesis do you think he who remains still
wanted this in the end I think that it always
had to occur otherwise there's no creation yes
I think this was all a path that M like was made
to happen there was no alternative see that's I
love this season a lot because this committed
a little bit more I can imagine there could be
things about like I want to rewatch it already
CU I'm like I feel like there's probably a thing
or two that I probably missed watch season one
and two together yeah yeah and I as I love the
dovet tale of how both of these really connect
very well it tells that multiversal angle where
a lot of it is when you hold a mirror up to
yourself it's not just Multiverse Cameo look
this person is played by this person instead I've
never not wanted Deadpool more like this this ver
the way they did this it wasn't even necessarily
Multiverse it was more time travel right um but it
told this the concepts of multiv the Thematic
things of Multiverse that I love told through
this time travel story this narrative and watching
how every character comes into confrontation with
their own choices the weight of it the the the
basic point of accountability I would say you know
where along in the tandem of action and events is
the fulcrum point of all these situations yeah it
was beautifully told because it's very it's very
philosophical and it's a a lot of it is a head
scratcher and I like the I I think there's a level
of bravery they decided to take because part one
only kind of touches on something that could be
a little difficult to grasp and I think here they
left a lot up to you really got to pay attention
this time I was worried I couldn't explain it
and I've read it yeah yeah they they really make
you pay attention very very close where you can
you kind of pick up on some of the details but I
imagine this is the kind of ending where people
will be going what is the ending expl I need to
know for once I think this merits some videos on
the internet saying it does like it's a it is a
very complex and you know like the word dense is
often thrown around when it just means a lot yeah
uh but it's more than just meaning a lot like that
it is it it is really con deconstructed through
its core there a theme and discussions throughout
and I love that we also still did get moments of
reference like the you know 616 adjacent being
the quantum realm with it seems like Easter egg
it seems like Kang will go from that version of
himself as he remains to being not that particular
one but a variant was referenced as being like a
one linear path so I'm really curious will we
I mean a court decision pending but will we see
he who remains K will we see that will we see
that version of him again if things uh shine in
major uh favor and Justice is in his side of
whatever happens wow he could explain um the
god of stories really well but then this subject
I'm scared of what the future will say about the
thing if I'm on the wrong side of knowing I'm the
un knowing god in a chair of pink just time Sid
back to this moment say something different and
as Justice prevailed and things were due and I
have a feeling the verdict will go this way well
note I gave no conclusion to that ellipses uh but
I I'm curious uh storytelling wise if we'll see
he remains again if Kang as instructed it would
seem they're doubling down on that Kang being our
Kang um because you know they asked about another
variant of him it's just a beautifully open
story while still giving closure yeah I mean
it's like what I love about the he who remains
is that like some versions of K King's more of
like a time like it's it's funny how he's being
pitched in the MCU as like this multiversal thing
but but he's I think he's more Associated as like
a time traveler a weirdo yeah weirdo time travel
pops up like that's a weird guy and in that book
I recommended you I was like oh I get this weird
guy but but even in that he's a time it's more
of time traveling but but everyone's kind of
associated with the multiversal stuff right yeah
because of how he's been pitched in the MCU and I
I think what what's so cool about he who remains
is like while he doesn't Dawn more of the classic
look as we saw in quantam Mania he is sort of
like the uh ultimate Lex Luther of sorts just
it's just a brain conglomerate the genius That
We crave from Kang and when he shows I'm like
man he is the ultimate threat like we need a I do
think we still need that Singularity of a threat
of like we need at least one king to latch on to
as that's like Prime King that we got to fear and
then multiversal King seems scary because we got
this guy you know and and I feel like when he who
remains is there just that power of knowledge and
foresight and navigation and patience you know um
is so great and I just like again the opposite
the mirroring that they did with going back to
season one The PV shots like you kept mentioning
like I when they were like talking to us when it
was like hello Loki giving a monologue at me
I'm uncomfortable cuz it's supposed to be it
was so good how do you feel during it Sean oh I
mean I was it's a very emotionally kind of rich
I don't know they cast such a PA over everything
and there is such kind of a somber baleful tone
throughout it and it's interesting because this
does feel like the end of something and the start
of something but this I like that they left it
all on the table in that for for the first time
I am actually quite pleased there was nothing
after the credits not even a Loki will return
for right now this is the end of something and I
am saddened by that in an appropriate way but I
appreciate that because it really earned just yeah
every heart swell every heart skip of a beat you
know and uh yeah I'm going to miss I'm going to
miss so many things but I'm also fascinated to see
what this becomes yeah and inspires I think this
ties Downey's Iron Man as my favorite Arc Landing
like going from the the Mischief arrogant to the
god of stories in his throne that he doesn't want
well I love that it's such an ironic tale for
him right yeah like this is this is completely
ironic he creates and he wanted to destroy and
like he matured into creating like he gets the
true burden of leadership like it's so lonely and
the most physical manifestation I love that Jos
Sweden wrote like cursed with glorious purpose
cuz it sounded cool yeah I mean he's just I mean
it had a purpose then but now it has a purpose
this has a real purp title of the damn episode
yeah it's he's he's lonely at the top and he
it real leaders normally don't want to be the
real leader he keeps rejecting throne and power
throughout this season and he just has to take it
unwillingly and those horns we we all mentioned
separately as like they they felt tangible they
had weight the crown looked heavy and those horns
felt like they were against him but part of him I
loved when he had like the Garb just manifest but
then it just felt so like it's natural but man it
looks awful like it looks awful to wheel I thought
it was really multi-layered in its emotion it's an
emotionality like it was beautiful but it was also
very tragic yeah it was um empowering and hopeful
but also incredibly sad well it starts off in in
such a I think it was smart to start with a very
fun kind of timey wiy thing where it's like oh
he's going just back to different points and he's
like rushing through it and he's like okay Chop
Chop business as usual you go down the thing and
then we oh we try again and I'm going to spend a
thousand years learning stuff like it starts off
in a very sort of fun place for this kind of story
that's like it gives you your cake up front it's
a good point the pacing is a really good point
and what I will say too uh one thing that I've
often said throughout this season about Loki's
personality of I kind of miss some of that fun
side of Loki seeing who he arked into by the end
of this I'm like oh way that actually works really
well like you wanted I remember episode three were
like I miss fun Loki and I was like I think we'll
either get him back or it'll earn it and like
I was hoping it would I didn't think would' go
here but this really earned the season this this
episode was Loki the show because of the rest
of the season yeah yeah yeah like we all hoped
yeah but I never would have imagined this story
cuz they were just kind of pitching him as like
serious TVA agent but the way they TI it to like a
new epic height in in a in a very ethereal way in
a in a manner that you kind of wouldn't expect but
it still feels like we naturally got here instead
of just going like big action scene or like big
debate yeah after big debate and I love how this
it's End season mirrors season 1 in such a way
of just like the the Revelation and again that or
Boris effect of what you're talking about of how
last one ends with he who remains you do bring
he who remains back but he he essentially ends
up becoming the opposite version of he who remains
was still fulfilling a similar role like wow what
a powerful and stepping out of time itself and I
really like what you said about the pacing because
I think the frenetic pacing in the opening made
the end somberness feels so much more like you're
tired like we had to go like and I'm tired I'm
glad that was one episode like it felt so good
as an hour of just like we lived through a lot
because he he did briefly become super TV agent
he did briefly like we lived it in this yeah it's
this like vibrating you know shifting thing that
slowly kind of Finds Its way and then calms to a
you know steady resolve and I didn't want to talk
like that that gelatinous phase I was just like
whoa that was so stunning yeah it hits you in a
different way uh again beautiful music throughout
I really appreciate the Craftsman [__] and
Craftsman [__] the Craftsman [__] Craftsman
[__] Craftsman [__] that they throw down that
[__] they CRA house that Craftsman [__] the
the way they craft uh together and like the story
of this is really that's really hard to write
something like this like structurally I could
just imagine that whiteboard or or like all those
index cards I cannot imagine it's the Charlie Day
for sure yeah when they're mapping the season like
this really feels like a complete this felt like
a showrunner like threw this one together yeah
and season one and two felt like it was all a
plan and it was literally a different team I love
that season two was a whole different Squad I'm
like how did you do this from that like you guys
found seeds that you seems like you planted you
weren't there to plant them it's just funny how
you Lo it in you have you have the Marvels out
right now where I think the even if you like it
I think the general consensus is that it's mess
everyone says it it it also really represents a
lot of Marvel's problems the problems that we all
have but the people who like it had fun with it
and this is the same day and yeah and it's just
kind of crazy how you have the ju abity of an or
por with real chaos and Decay and atrophy and what
story creation can be you have like yes this one
is not as fun nowhere near it doesn't aim for fun
but damn is it like composed as [__] from every
aspect of film making to storytelling and acting
all of it and pacing at it every every nugget of
what someone on set is required for before during
and after it's all present here in a way that
speaks so such loud volumes and then the other
one is but it's fun you know don't the MCU Decay
and it's it's so interesting to get both sides
the same week I would be fascinated to know how
this and this doesn't even have a Sor it's just
funny like this doesn't even have a post credit
scene it's the opposite the just talking about
the post SC the other one had such an important
postcard scene it's such a messy film yeah it
makes me curious how they made this because this
doesn't feel like you could have done like modular
re-shoot and stuff like that and I'm sure this
is the first one of thato without no re-shoot on
the show it shows it shows they they locked those
scrips ahead of time and hey maybe they had some
stuff with the earlier TVA you know Mutiny bit
but like yeah it really feels like they locked
everything and mapped this out ahead of time
yeah there's no way to go back and like let's
check that no no this is done this is buttoned
up yeah I love how they brought it back to how
he's a God and what and what a god with power can
do it's about responsibility and realizing that
yeah it's it's not defining what that means and
then inflicting that on everybody else it's just
accepting what it means to be in that position
of God all right Coy uh you got to get out of
here I got to edit uh but can you wrap us up in 30
seconds what you think this ending means for the
future of the MCU especially Eko uh I obviously
ekko's next so it's G to tie in Loki's gonna open
the season and go like death um it's uh I believe
in 30 seconds what's gonna happen is we're gonna
have the elements so distractive of my own joke
being so offensive um the idea of opening the show
uh as we go further the The Narrative show that
is Marvel I do think we're going to see elements
of of the god of stories not directly represented
I think there is a chance we'll see him in secret
Wars I think there's a chance we see him briefly
in Kang Dynasty as we see time unraveling and like
time being conquered but I wouldn't count on
Kang Dynasty necessarily I would assume secret
ORS it'd be a big moment it'd be a big pop and
he's so overpowered he's almost like a Celestial
like um like a Living Tribunal I could see him on
the plane of the gods that are more like the ones
we met in Elemental I mean uh um eternals the
more like that level of God so I could see it
in secret War but what I think is going to happen
going forward is we see Kang depending on how the
story goes be introduced in more narratives
and we build to how we've met time unraveling
working for Kang being on so many disperate parts
we see how powerful is in different places but the
big thing for Easter egg hunters is all those
timelines mean Fox Sony all those things so
we're going to see that this unraveling and the
keeping instead of the decaying the not pruning
is allowing these universes to collide so the
only thing we're getting for a film next year
is Deadpool the events of this are how I believe
Deadpool is going to relate I think Deadpool can
travel through them because the time Turner but I
think because of what just happened here they're
colliding so incursion events are going to be
timelines visualized by planets and dimensional
folds because of the end of this episode which
is beautiful because it is actually what fige
promised with the stabbing of Kang that is what
started all of this because that's what had to not
happen in order for this Multiverse to occur so
that Ora Boris is now complete but the launching
Point into the Collision of all these things is
where we're going to start this next phase they
should end this phase here and call that the next
thing cuz it's a lot cleaner but they haven't had
a map for a little bit so I think Deadpool is
the beginning of the unraveling of the events
caused by the end of this year and if K gets to
stay it'll be him uh building power setting up
to Kang Dynasty and then ultimately Secret Wars
where we might see Loki again Amen to that that
was well done dude that's crazy I love Comics it's
crazy how he became like how he just he wanted to
be a dictator and he ends up becoming the exact
opposite he becomes the benevolent God creation
just want to have free will it's just so funny and
I love that he wears green the color of creation
like there's so much Beauty in this yeah and then
with the with the opposite of like King's colors
his colors are purple and it's like green too
and the tree of life being purple and green like
the flowering Purple colors too you know God damn
it's good TV all righty guys uh that was brilliant
I love that um what did you guys think leave
your thoughts down below what was your favorite
moment from this thank you KY for being here guys
thank you for being joining us I'll catch you all
soon